Throughout America's adventure in free government our basic purposes have been to keep the peace,
to foster progress in human achievement, and to enhance liberty, dignity, and integrity among peoples
and among nations. Progress toward these noble goals is persistently threatened by the conflict
now engulfing the world. It commands our whole attention, absorbs our very being. Global in scope,
atheistic in character, ruthless in purpose, and insidious in method. Unhappily the danger it poses
promises to be of indefinite duration. To meet it successfully, there is call for, not so much the emotional
and transitory sacrifices of crisis, but rather those which enable us to carry forward steadily, surely,
and without complaint the burdens of a prolonged and complex struggle with liberty, the stake.
Crises they will continue to be. In meeting them whether foreign or domestic, great or small,
there is a recurring temptation to feel that some spectacular and costly action
could become the miraculous solution to all current difficulties.
But each proposal must be weighed in the light of a broader consideration: the need to maintain balance
in and among national programs, balance between our essential requirements as a nation and the duties
imposed by the nation upon the individual, balance between actions of the moment and the national welfare
of the future. Good judgement seeks balance and progress. Lack of it eventually finds imbalance
and frustration. You and I, my fellow citizens need to be strong in our faith that all nations, under God,
will reach the goal of peace with justice. May we be ever unswerving in devotion to principle,
confident but humble with power, diligent in pursuit of the Nation's great goals.